what about you what's the worst trip
you've had so yeah we did them with some
like random girls like they just like
liked our music we told them to go to
the studio like they came with us he was
with us actually yeah boom because he
was in the booth he started rapping
about some crazy deep stuff like nobody
loves me everybody today
don't listen to that life isn't promised
why are we here I just want to be like
I'm like yo hey yo I'm on this room so
then everything started changing like
boom like so the girls they start asking
me questions I'm trying to write my
verses I'm listening to the beat like
I'm focused then they start asking me
like why aren't you talking to us like
why aren't you showing me any attention
like they asked me like literally why
don't you love me like why don't you
love us they're on insurance too so I'm
like I'm understanding like okay this
[__] crazy like it's a wild thing to ask
somebody yeah they asked like why don't
you love him I'm like I love everybody
like I'm you don't say I'm like I'm a
down-to-earth [__] like but they kept
just like talking to me I had to just
like walk away and just like lay under
the piano and I was just like getting
away from everybody just laying on the
piano